ladies and gentlemen this Bo Derek and
mr. Dudley Moore
yeah Wow thank you thank you good
evening mrs. D
good evening mr. d mm-hmm hair looks
different I must say it certainly is a
pleasure to see you again you know I
mean how many years ago was it it was 10
years deadly 10 10 10 I remember doing a
film with the girl who looked exactly
like you about that number of years ago
fr but the mind plays tricks would that
the body could as well you know well you
know just just seeing you actually
actually makes the the memories of
working on that picture fairly gush
forward you know in a great surge of
nostalgia yeah anyway how am
oh this is awful how I run it how I run
it though that we should be here tonight
presenting the award for best costume
design when as I recall it's hardly
worth reading the rest of the you
paragraph we did most of our
distinguished work on that film wearing
absolutely no costume whatsoever deadly
as I recall you were wearing a little
something well let's not get clinical
the designers of course who have been
nominated tonight fortunately had a
great deal more to work with or to put
it another way No well no I'm not really
quite sure how to say that
your turn bear yes the award for best
costume design will go to one of the
following gifted artists Deborah and
their drew men whose creations ran from
African tribal robes to fast food
uniforms in coming to America
James HSN for his line of seductive
French sportswear in Dangerous Liaisons
Jane Robinson who closed the last gospel
at the British Empire in a handful of
dust
Patricia Norris who makes the Wild West
with old Hollywood in Sunset
and milena Kenan arrow will recreate in
the post-war fashion boom including no
end of car coats in Tucker the man and
his dream
and the Oscar goes to James Atchison for
dangerous
Thank You Academy I'd like to firstly
thank my assistant Frank Gardner and the
wonderful team of people that actually
cut and sewed these costumes I'd also
like to thank the the wonderful group of
actresses that withstood the rigors of
18th century course 'try with such
patience and good humor I'd like to
thank Norma Heyman and Hank moon gene
and Stephen Frears the director and I'd
also like to thank Christopher Hampton
who wrote the play and who wrote this
wonderful screenplay that inspired us
all thank you very much
the 61st annual Academy Awards will
return with savvy maple sugaring Gregory
Hines